okay so what I'm going to try to go
through today which is not off your
brilliant start is how to use the event
handling system in matplotlib for
building interactive figures so the the
inter if you've ever used the pan or the
zoom tools in MATLAB or you've used or
you noticed you know when you move your
mouse around you get that little thing
in the bottom corner that tells you
where your cursor is that's all run
through a map framework that is internal
to MATLAB and you can hook into it for
your own purposes so it's
is everyone else's done those going at
about the same speed as this er
okay I guess I'm not sure to do well
well I wait for this machine to set
itself up so I can start demoing things
so who has the environment set up and is
ready to go and I Python two people okay
or is that always making who isn't
making progress towards happening in the
environment and ipython setup
you should you should run this command
because you're gonna need five tables
because we're going to read an issue if
I file later and you're going to need a
2.0 beta from Khan Forge
that sounds right
oh boy
that's a lie I wouldn't do after fun
okay okay well this is starting off as a
complete disaster but at least at least
it'll at least it has to get better
right so what we're gonna talk about
today is just gonna it's going to it
will hopefully be a quick introduction
to the event handling system there's a
tremendous amount of depth you that you
could get into you can literally write a
book about it what one of the other core
developers and Root recently published a
book called interactive application
using matplotlib and the the blurb is
learn how Lincoln could use matplotlib
to save the earth from hordes of
ravenous space where rabbits just
plodding your data won't save the world
but turning your opossum track into
interactive applications will hook your
users explore their data and gain
greater insight into their problems this
book will walk the reader through the
process of turning a simple radar of
your entire useful has a hazardous
offense tracker so you too can spot
where the space where rabbits are going
to strike next um and in addition
everything going to show today is
documented to one degree or another
of course they can't type
oh wait wait stop do it so this this
this tutorial which is on the map all
the website is kind of the basis for
what I'm going to be talking about I'm
going to extend the examples go a little
bit off from this but this if later you
want to read more this is a very good
resource right alright so as I mentioned
there's a whole event system and the way
matplotlib separates concerns is that
there's the the all the artists which
are you figure your axes that familiar
the object-oriented aspect of matt
partland
and that's the in memory representation
of your figure and then that's connected
up with a canvas or what we call
backends which are responsible for
turning that need memory representation
into something on the screen you know if
you're running through a egg and then to
one of the toolkit this is what gives
you the image you can click on this is
this also this architecture also does is
to swap out and get SVG PDF EPS all from
the same in-memory representation so the
GUI frameworks which we have ship
embeddings for all have hooks that when
you provide GUI events such as clicking
or typing a key there's a bridge from
the GUI framework down to matplotlib
that generates one of these events that
you can then hook into and to receive
and do work on and these fall down into
roughly three different classes of
events there's what we call it you could
call active events and this is the you
know the button press key press and pick
events which this is something where the
users actively telling you I'd like to
interact now you know they're clicking
they're hitting a key there's the the
passive ones which are the motion notify
and the all the enter the enter and
leave events these correspond to you
know where your
so if you still the XY coordinates in
the lower corner this is is a hookup to
the mass motion event and then the draw
and resize events are kind of internal
events that that tell anything that
needs to watch the exact size of the
figure that needs to redraw itself which
is mostly useful if you get into for
instance splitting which is a technique
for making figures render faster by not
re-rendering things that haven't changed
and that is an entirely separate 1/2
hour tutorial all right
and we're still making progress okay so
does than you okay has anyone gotten
this all the environment installed and I
Python started great one person so if
you if you start up by Python and run
percent run Explorer 0 sorry I'm just
very flustered that this is not going
smooth like ah okay I mean it should
work I I was hoping to I mean I was
hoping there's some that show off some
of the 2.0 features which is why having
people install from kind of Forge but if
you I guess if you I've not tried this
in a stock on anaconda environment so
we'll see what breaks but that is an
option for trying so in 0 0 Explorer
this is just the simplest thing you
could hook up so the callbacks you need
to register are a function that simply
take in a single argument which it is
the event to be able to capture this if
we use a global variable we can stash
this to look at later and then we just
print out all the attributes that are on
this on the event
that better oh that's too much
and then the way you tell Matt Paul live
that you'd like to register a callback
to be hooked up in the event system is
you get hold of the canvas which is the
backend that's responsible for actually
drawing the figure and is hooked up to
the GUI framework and they has a method
MPL connect you give her the name of the
event you would like and then the
function that should get that event all
right
all right so people who have any any
version of a Python and map well that
this should and this should this one
should be runnable in the stock one so
if people can start playing with that
and I'm going to see if what will break
is this just in your route one
Hey
I got interactive monitoring
can I install things in your root
environment
so the problem here is that the
packaging upstream is switched from qt4
to qt5 without switching all of the
dependencies that that default using QT
4 and the easiest thing to just roll
everything back to Qt for at least until
those those things get sorted so who has
successfully one zero zero on their
computer it's great greater than one
point six to try to force it to be 2.0
and you think the full Conda rest come
to four slash label /r c is a channel
huh okay then give up and use one flag
so when your so if you switch which
event you're looking at you can you can
explore through which of those events
you can get out and what they look like
when you get them
fine
alright alright so we're gonna do it
this way
I can type
hooray okay so right
so right so if you see as I click the
you've got these nice printouts if you
change which bottom you're clicking it
shows you which button and on the key on
the mass events
you also get if you hold down shift and
click no there you you also get the
modifier if I can do both at once LT
appears to be captured by the system so
you can you can capture the modifier
keys you can capture Mouse events
so if you change the button pressed
akitoki press which when you and it
automatically reruns the file and now as
you type keys
you see the key show up one danger if
you're going to if you want to write
something which uses that looks at key
bindings be careful of the default ones
first in cell turns your Y your x-axis
to log I'll show your y-axis K terms
your x-axis save tries to s tries to
save so you want to turn those off which
I'll show you how to do in a later
example alright so how many people have
successfully hooked up to a different
event than button press I move you have
tried to hook up to a different event
than button press ok
okay so we're going to move on to the
next one
right
all right so this code at the top here
just removes all the default key
bindings so that you know we don't try
to go home we don't try to save any of
that so in the first example we just had
a function that we hooked up to the
callback stack to accept the events and
do something with it this you know this
is convenient because the function it's
very easy to find a function however
functions are typically stateless so if
you wanted to do anything where you'd
capture multiple events and sequence to
see if the users were doing you know
clicking multiple places it's convenient
to use a callable object as as the
callback so here it is simply you know
this is a this is a call class we hook
it up to the key press events and
and when it gets the events it wall it
prints them to the screen and it also
captures them in in a buffer that we can
look at and then once you once you have
those events cache now you can start
doing
yesterday now that you've started
capturing things you can you know at
later times do computation so you can
imagine doing something like not
capturing a bunch of fluency wedding for
a further event like the Enter key and
the to trigger some processing so
everyone could play with this for a bit
so you know a obvious extension this is
to add a method onto this which would
yes
uhh
so can you pan and zoom your graph or is
it is it in line just a static image you
need to search the back end from inline
to Qt or dist use ipython is probably
the simplest way to get this working
right so now Ivy's extension on this is
just to take this need to add a method
which will print out the string the user
typed in through the deck so if people
could play with this for a little bit
alright have people got in this who it
has got in this to at least run great
alright so I'm going to give you five
minutes
all right who is having trouble of
getting this to work at all I will come
around and see if I can
also dairy products
all right ok so we are going to continue
so the the next thing you might want to
do is in your in your callback functions
instead of just taking the events and
blindly doing something with them the
events carry quite of information as
they hope you discovered in the first
step and so now you can start making
decisions about what to do based on the
information in the in the event so in
this case we have to find another class
for handling handling the callbacks
because we're going to try to do
something stateful again when we
constructor we're gonna give it a line
2d object and this is a bunch of
boilerplate alright so we just we stash
the current data we stash the line
itself and then the color cycle will be
used later later do below and then we
connect up to methods on this object to
the canvas called to the callbacks
button press on bun nan key so if you
just look at on button the first thing
it does is the callbacks are registered
per axis and accesses are associated
with figures so if you've got a
multi-axis figure you might you might
only want to accept events that happen
in one axis or another so this first
test is just a check to make sure we're
working the axis we think we're we're
hanging we only want to accept the left
mouse button when there are no modifiers
clicked so that's where this is checking
really I keep there you go then we're
going to grab the X&Y location from the
event I append it to the list and then
update the artist with that data and
this draw Idol is a command that ask the
canvas to the next time it's convenient
for the GUI
please redraw yourself so free that
wears should have empty figure and now
as you click around you should be able
to build up a line
and now the the second half of this is
every with the method on key well it's
just going to advance through colors and
then change the color of that line
whenever we hit the key see so we run
this again whole bunch and now as I hit
see hopefully you see
you can ice and thick so now you can see
we can cook we can cycle the color in
response to a keystroke so yeah this is
kind of a toy example but you could
imagine that if you've got some GUI
button you can click to change the color
you can lick that to change the
visibility if you're interested in and
providing your users a way to you know
do something to the data in response to
user input so so other things that you
know too if you I'm going to give you
another ten minutes or so to play with
this some interesting things to do might
be if you shift click or right click to
remove the nearest point you know so if
you've got users that need to build up
some user input path on top of say an
image to trace out a line or you know
it's a rough guess for starting some
algorithm you could try mapping the
number keys to changing the line width
or you know using the Escape key to just
completely clear your data and start
again so I'm going to give you a few
minutes and walk around
okay so if here's most people have
managed to get this running
so let's see what three is okay so the
picking the pick event is an event that
allows you interact very specifically
with artists in the figure the the
keyboard and the mouse events are very
general there anything that hits the
canvas you'll just get where those user
events are the the pick event allows you
to select specific as you say only fire
when I want to user clicks on this
particular artist and then it gives you
back additional information about the
artist depending on what type of artist
is what type of artist it is for example
for line 2d you get back the index of
where in the XY list that pic was so if
we run this so the in the title I
promised time series so the time series
are going to be looking at is
temperature get hourly temperature data
pulled from the BWI weather station so
what this is is this is a badly
formatted y-axis um or x-axis so this is
daily averages for the last almost two
years at BWI and now if I click on these
points it will print out the row of the
data frame so if you look at
so BWI is the data frame which has all
of the hourly measurements in it
there's just the temperature and the
date and if you look at BWI this is
beautiful columns is the aggregated by
day of the mean the mean standard
deviation May and Max and the
percentiles of the weather of the
temperature measured on that day and
then what's plotted here is the means
per day and it's hooked up so that when
you click on it you can drill down and
see the statistics associated with that
day and so again now if you're if you're
just need to provide some rudimentary
data exploration you know so that we're
the you know the marks on the screen
aren't quite enough you want to write a
bit more context or you want to you want
to report out the name of something or
you've got you know paragraphs of text
that go with each point using a pick
event like this I'm gonna bring it up
again using a pick event like this where
you just use the index to slice into
some parallel data structure to your XY
points is a very powerful way to quickly
provide additional user feedback so so
yes this so people can play with this I
mean the things you could try doing in
addition to what it already does so I
should show you labeled data so looking
looking at this you can start to see
some interesting outliers like like like
those so that there's a couple
in the in the source code in the in the
file there's some little helper
functions such as labeled a twisters
we'll just put an annotation on a
specific date
of course they can't type
this should have been funnier if I could
type faster and and why didn't that work
nope
there we go so I managed to pick the one
cold weekend last October so I'm gonna
bring the code back up if people want
I'm gonna walk around again while people
play with this so yeah so all right if
you'll manage to get this example to run
this is what requires high tables all
right so who needs help no one needs
help are you all bored and check your
email
pie tables
so so there's a there's a f5 file in the
repository that is their extracted data
from NOAA so we're that where this came
from is again
it there you can get hourly logs by the
year per weather station which contain
you know a tremendous amount of
information per line and I've just gone
through and just pulled out just the
temperature if you look at 99 - get the
data is the that's the code that will go
out and download the files from NOAA if
you wanted to reconstruct this for a
different weather station
right and you won't have questions
all right
okay so if you move on to the next file
which some people already have done
so this isn't so much an interactive
example and more of a suggestion of how
to get the most out of library so the
underlying functions in bet we expose
them at fault live are very low-level
right we expect a single array for X a
single rate for y you know and we're
providing very low level you know glyphs
or marks to steal language you languish
from other plotting libraries and we
strongly suggest that you write yourself
helper functions that use one or more
than relying plotting methods that know
something about the structure of your
data first since and this you know this
plots the aggregated error bar this is
create an error bar it knows that it's
getting in a data frame which hasn't
index a mean and a standard deviation
that you'd want to use and then it fills
the region between pulling the min and
Max columns out of your data frame right
this is very non general however it's
very tuned but it's very tuned to this
particular use case and you get a graph
that looks like this which it was
obviously has much more information than
just you know the single plot from the
previous example but you know but again
there's no native there's no native
function that will do this so you need
to write your own to build that
additional functionality so at this
point
so I'm not even sure what this does
before I can get the code so I was
walking on someone asked could you click
and cause it to plot so this is a couple
hundred lines of interactive code that
ideally should be under you should have
been able to you I should ideally should
be understandable after the first half
of this tutorial if you click on so that
the top panel is the temperature
aggregated by month if you click on any
of the months come on
you get a graph of the temperature and
by day and if you click on the day you
get the the graphs hourly in the third
plot and then so now this is visit new
this is only at showing how to add data
if you click on these down here well or
all of them anything that gets picked
will remove itself and if you shift
click I'm holding down the shift key and
clicking on the and these which will
remove the months so now if you were
interested in comparing all the summers
you go through and get all the summers
or
you're comparing February and every in
August so so if people can people get
this to run all right so I'm just going
I'm now going to just talk through what
this code does and then for the rest of
the tutorial I'll just turn you loose
playing with it and I'll walk around and
answer questions all right so the first
thing in here this is two helper
function to load that the pre-processed
data that's interesting when it's done
with that Unicode just sets up the
figure were the three actives that we're
going to need labels them turns the grid
on and make sure that the limits are set
correctly the share Y means that all of
the y axes of those three plots are are
linked so if you zoom on one the other
two will also zoom and then this sets
the X limits to correctly scale to
whatever the two either to 32 days for
the month or 24 20 24 hours for the time
this plot aggregated error bar is just
our friend from the last example that
you know just creates the those band
plots and then this aggregated time
trace is the is a is the object that
takes care of both managing the data and
then hooking up the all the hooking up
into the events and plotting as required
it takes in a fair amount of arguments
the hourly data is dianna irrigated data
the label is if you name it so now if
you want to create multiple of time
traces on the same in the same figure so
if you want to compare BWI and JFK for
example
and then it takes in the three axes that
it's going to use for the the year scale
then once again the day scale in this
particular case they're all in the same
figure however there's no particular
reason has to be the case you could have
each of these in their own window or if
you're building if you're building out a
custom GUI you could have these and
different very different parts of your
GUI and they'd still be able to talk to
each other so the init is all just
entirely bookkeeping and then we
register three pick three pick event
message messages for each of the three
axes so the simplest one is in the in
the top axes we just check to see are we
in the right place if we don't have an
artist for whatever reason bail and
otherwise use the index pull that index
out of the out of the aggregated by
month data figure out what the date the
month in the year are and then pass
those to this other plot T by date which
goes through and does the data munging
required to pull the the month out of
the monthly aggregated data and then
plots it and then this here so GID
is a user field on all map polyp artists
that's for whatever you want to do with
it so it's a global identify er
internally we don't use it at all but we
carry it around everywhere and we will
also get Zeppelin the vector back ends
so if you want to label an artist for
your own purposes this is a good place
to do it this is as opposed to the set
set and get label which is the label of
that artist that we use when generating
the buttons and then the on month pick
is almost identical we we just recheck
to see from the right axis if rolling on
the shift key go through and remove that
artist otherwise walk through pull the
the month the year month and day out and
pass it to a by our plot function which
just you know pulls that one day worth
of data
from the Laroy our alligator we handed
in and just plots it and the the
simplest one is the de Leon pick was
just if you if it's been picked delete
yourself and then at the end to actually
create these things we use set up
temperature figure to get our figure and
the three actives are going to use
festival to the the init method and then
just put a nice label on top so
hopefully this is shown use the the
power that you have through this event
system to build very rich interactive
graphs the I mean the cost is there
still you have to do a fair amount of
work to get it to work as you need but
the power is there if you need it so I'm
just gonna walk around and answer
questions until the end of the tutorial